Olivia Munn and Chrissy Mets were also
honored over the weekend and we were
exclusively with them both starting a
with Olivia Munn who is opening up about
her own girl hero her mama the eg on
lines lauren zima
one piece of advice you'd give to your
younger self my mom used to say that I
mean that's growing up she feel like
you're so stubborn why do you always
talk back and the other day she said I
just have to say I'm I'm I'm very happy
I never told you to shut up
don't shut up don't shut up Olivia has
taken a stand against sexual harassment
in Hollywood and while that led her to
be ostracized by some she said her mom
came up with a back-up plan
mom don't know how much money you have
but have to be enough to buy a big beach
house in Costa Rica so here's my thought
okay who need Hollywood who care about
Hollywood we make smoothie bar on beach
in Costa Rica Olivia was honored as the
first ever girl hero Awards along with
others including Chrissy Metz and we
wondered if her role on this is us has
given her baby fever in real life as
well I haven't been like chomping at the
bit ten children only because I want to
be the best mom and I and I still have
so many things that I want to do also
honoring Olivia Munn here today and
we're like dream casting could she be on
this as US can we make this happen when
I cutesies Hey my wheels are turning I
would love that I'm a huge fan of the
show and I'm an of Chrissy's so I'll do
anything with crispy and just do our own
movie
[Music]